do you guys think like um
when it comes to interracial like white
men are desired by
um black women now
because i've see i've seen like more
black women with white men now one thing
i would say from black
growing up between i grew up between an
ethnically diverse area with
my dad no with my mom and then and not
necessarily the diverse area my dad
and it
in certain pockets of essex like when i
went to visit my dad i'm seeing that
there was a generation of black men just
hating on black women that they actually
became so revolted that they went to the
other side because they're just like
well you are just gonna call us like
drug buzzers say that we look like
gorillas these are actually showing us
love so it's almost like in certain
pockets the black man has pushed the
black woman away when the black woman
has actually been
loyal to a point and then eventually
gets the point of like well we're gonna
date someone
did you see that
that guy the other day that was on that
went viral for that and he called the
black woman yeah that's why that's what
i said the comment we did um a tick tock
duet on it and that his viewpoint
as a mixed race man is a view of many of
people in like certain pockets of essex
of that time right because that's what
pushed what was the social norms in
their areas is like
blonde blue eyes brunette busty tits
fake lips and ironically now it's even
getting closer to black features
everything is black features apart from
actually being black
um
do you find that men want to actually
wife those girls because i from what
i've seen the girls that have like the
botox lips and like that look suit with
the fake tits like they'll screw them
for a night but a mother of their kids
wife um doesn't but that's that's where
where i think the modern woman gets it
lost she's when she goes out on a night
out
the man's giving all the attention to
them kind of women because he wants to
chop them for a night you're in the club
to chop you're not in a club to find a
future wife yeah and then her head gets
[ __ ] up because she's almost natural
oh men aren't into me but just in this
setting in this time
i know
the mandarin when we go out if they're
going ibiza
they're not looking for
a bible with the bible going natural
they're looking for this skimpiest g
string and they're trying to bust the
cheeks open as quick as possible yeah so
it's just like you need to look at the
settings you're in and then apply logic
to that
[Music]
that's interesting just to touch on that
so you think um i'm sorry that's why
i've said that you know men go to strip
clubs
because they want to look at women that
are look like that but they don't want
to necessarily work with me like that
and i think like you just said i think
women of that this generation because
men have shown that type of woman so
much attention they're kind of getting
it twisted and they think oh i need to
look like that to get attention now and
it's like no don't do that yeah don't do
that that's just like that's just what
we do when we feel a little bit i don't
know whatever i know man body count or
triple figures and they're like you know
what i watched this girl she's a reaver
she's into islam she don't have social
media she don't go out she's
i'm like the only guys he's ever slept
with and that's who they end up with you
know i'm saying
but they've gone and done whatever
they've done you know
why do you guys think when they're
talking about interracial relationships
it's always like black and white like
you never hear people talk about asian
and white
or
or like asian and black like it's always
black and white it's the most divisive
why because of the history between black
blacks and whites being oppressed it's
the most divisive all the the semantic
words we have behind it it's almost like
that's the reason why when even when you
look at
white and black culture probably
has
more things that are analogous than say
black and arab
like a lot of if you're black and
non-muslim you're probably going to have
less likelihood arab muslim than you are
with say the average white person well
the arabs were like
real like
worse no no they're like they castrated
the men yeah they couldn't breed the
women yeah yeah so so like why do you
like we don't really hear about that
though so why is one more divisive than
the other it's loud if you look at
america ruled the world so i think
americans at that time even though
they're not the natives but americans
were seen as white so that's why
that's probably why we talk about it now
i think they just they just mashed up
the whole information chain on that one
because you don't learn that in school i
had to look online for that stuff no
that
oh god no i've i read um
thomas sowell has a book on it and it's
oh gosh when they they talked about the
arab slave trade oh it's it's it's
western i would say it's wrestling
it's the worst oh my god i was scarred
after like reading the account oh my
gosh
it's like when they they had the slaves
have to walk across the desert and it
was like over 50 of them died in the
walk and then the guys that made it
would get castrated
like they were known for being like
like gruesome all across the world
and that's the thing is that when you
were talking earlier on about culture
i think um people within the west
generally have a similar culture that
they can that they can try and gravitate
towards like a general culture if that
makes sense and then
what happens is when another culture
comes in it's worse because it's like i
would say i'm more likely to marry a
white woman than i am an arab
i'd agree with you what i'm saying more
likely i'm more likely to marry a uh
a white woman than it is a someone from
pakistan
and it's because there's a similar
culture there like when i said when you
go into that culture
no you don't there's nothing of like
there's no similarities
do you know if anything you're probably
and a lot of their cultures maybe their
first generation has changed but when
you're looking at from over there they
have a car system against their own
right you remember as a black you are
the bottom of the bottom yeah if they're
putting other asians who are darker
skinned because obviously looking at the
history of when you say look at india if
you're a darker skinned you as a worker
if you're light-skinned you was
in the house
so when you're looking at bringing the
black people into even when you look at
gandhi before he did his whole change
and did what he did for india he was an
avid racist when he was studying in
south africa he said
um
the most barbaric human is a darker
skinned man then it's indians and then
it's whites and it's only switched it
around and that's gandhi who is like the
the most peaceful man ever to live yeah
but he was announced but that's enough
yeah
for another day